personne n'est prêt à crier au loup mais
tout le monde se prépare au pire le
réseau de la santé pourrait bientôt
manquer d'équipements pour réaliser des
épidurale une intervention couramment
utilisés notamment lors des
accouchements j'ai envie d'avoir les
coups durs a fait que ce soit que ça me
stresse de plus six jours de mon action
un disque et non madame désolé il manque
de cathéter ou quoi que ce soit là le
cathéter est plus dure elle est un petit
tube de plastique qu'on introduit entre
les os de la colonne la patient pour lui
éjecté un produit anti douleur durant
son accouchement on sait que pour les
femmes enceintes les femmes en travail
c'est la meilleure méthode qu'on a pour
soulager les patients et sans caténaire
on se retrouve seulement avec les
alternatives qui sont pas aussi
efficaces certes un cathéter utilisé au
québec sont en rupture de stock d'autres
sur le point de l'être nous ici à saint
justin quand on ne fait notre inventaire
on sait que on a en a suffisamment long
pour supporter nos femmes enceintes qui
viennent accoucher ici au moins pour
tous mpt ouaddou est probablement une
partie du mois de septembre québec et
ottawa font actuellement des démarches
auprès des fournisseurs dr européens et
américains qui offrent des produits
similaires et on s'attend à ce qu'ils
soient
semblables à ceux qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui est que y ait aucune
différence pour les femmes enceintes
verront pas la différence entre un
cathéter ou l'autre en principe si ces
produits sont rapidement prouvé la
pénurie devrait se résorber sans trop de
problèmes il faut pas alarmer les
patientes à ce sujet là on va être là
pour l avons continué d'avec le pourrait
elle est la personne qui va se faire
refuser des culturales l'empêchent un
accouchement c'est déjà un événement
suffisamment stressé sans avoir à se
préoccuper de ce genre de problème
dix-sept jeunes mères maintenant que
c'est ma deuxième grossesse je m'attends
à la voix c'est dans mon clan pocket et
la mettons que j'arrive et que je les
pabx et je suis pas prêt
psychologiquement me tombe trois centres
hospitaliers québécois dont sainte
justine ont déjà commencé ils veulent
lui certains produits de remplacement ce
normand grondin radio canada montréal